chers collègues monsieur le ministre
madame l'a rapporteur nous poursuivons
aujourd'hui des travaux de notre
commission d'enquête sur la pénurie
médicament et les choix de l'industrie
pharmaceutique française en auditionnant
Monsieur François brode ministre de la
santé et de la prévention je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre de vous
être mobilisés aujourd'hui votre
audition traditionnelle à la fin des
travaux de la commission d'enquête et
des de la mission parlementaire
d'information et des missions
parlementaires d'information intervient
deux jours à peine après l'annonce d'une
liste de 450 médicaments essentiels
deux jours avant l'audition de votre
collègue du gouvernement Roland Lescure
mise à veget chargée de l'industrie une
première liste de 280 médicaments
avaient été publiés avec un peu de ma
liste nous pourrions croire que nos
travaux rythmes avantageusement la
communication du gouvernement en matière
de pénurie de médicaments mais je
n'oserais aller plus loin dans
l'interprétation de la situation
la publication de la liste de ces
quelques 450 médicaments essentiels
marque une nouvelle étape de la feuille
de route pénurie et vous pourrez nous
préciser selon quel processus elle a été
établie entre consultations des sociétés
savantes retour d'expérience de la
société française d'anesthésie
réanimation intervention de la Société
française de pharmacie clinique et
discussions avec le comité
d'organisation dans la mesure nous
avions déjà eu un échange avec la
Direction générale des entreprises sur
la constitution de la première liste et
donc on aimerait savoir ce qui entre la
liste d'origine les fameux 58 premiers
qui avaient été validés le premier
médicament validé qu'elle est un peu
l'évolution entre entre les deux et
est-ce que le process est resté le même
le président de la République a par
ailleurs annoncé la constitution d'une
alors je cite liste cœur
et est-ce que cela sous-entend le
corollaire que les 400 autres ne sont
pas concernés par les problèmes de
production en tout cas ne sont pas mis
au même niveau que c'est que ces 50
quelques 50 choisis en outre je souhaite
que vous puissiez nous dire comment le
calendrier des relocalisations annoncées
mardi a été établie car nous n'oublions
pas qu'il y a 3 ans quasiment jour pour
jour le président de la République avait
annoncé que la France serait en mesure
d'ici trois ans de reproduire
conditionner et distribuer du
paracétamol
mais l'usine séquence de Roussillon nous
avons visité le chantier devrait entrer
en production d'ici 2025 seulement donc
nous explicités pourquoi le délai même
si on imagine aisément qu'il y a des
raisons
essentielles à cela les mesures de
relocalisation de la production
s'inscrivent donc d'évidence dans la
durée mais pendant ce temps les pénuries
continuent
assis j'ai été alerté il y a deux jours
sur la pénurie de bétail un
anti-vertinegineux qui n'est certes pas
un MTM selon la terminologie de la NSM
et
terminologie que nous utilisons la LSM
le considère néanmoins comme d'usage
très élevé puisqu'il concerne plus de 40
000 patients chaque année ceci pose par
ailleurs la question de
l'approvisionnement de médicaments
essentiels pour la qualité de vie des
malades mais réglementairement non
considérés comme tel vous nous direz
comment vous entendez dialoguer avec les
associations de patients concernés par
ce type de difficulté je pourrais
également citer par exemple certains
traitements contre la maladie Parkinson
on a eu de toute façon contenu de la
liste des 3500 et médicaments en pénurie
tout un tas de situations extrêmement
problématiques qu'on parle
d'anticancéreuses spécifiques pour
certains cancers
hématologiques ou alors de
d'anti-épileptiques
qui sont prescrits sous forme
pédiatrique
enfin il y a quelques semaines les
pédiates de 5 pays européens dont la
France ont déjà alerté sur les risques
de pénurie à l'automne prochain
quelles assurances pouvez-vous nous
donner sur les moyens mis en oeuvre pour
faire en sorte que les difficultés
graves rencontrées à l'hiver dernier ne
se reproduisent pas
au-delà de l'intitulé plan blanc c'est
bien sûr sur le contenu de ce plan que
nous vous interrogeons car qu'il soit
blanc rouge ou d'une autre couleur
clairement c'est la façon dont les
choses doivent se dérouler et nous nous
situons
suffisamment en amont en tout cas pour
que nous voyons clairs au niveau des
stocks et de la disponibilité des
médicaments avant la crise d'épidémique
et hivernale à la rentrée de septembre
surtout ces sujets je vais maintenant
vous céder la parole pour un bref repoin
introductif puis madame Laurence Cohen
rapporteur de notre commission d'enquête
vous posera une première série de
questions je précise que cette audition
est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte-rendu publié avant
de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête et passible
des peines prévues aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je
vous y invite donc à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
enlevant la main droite et en disant que
je le jure
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole
merci merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs
je sais et vous venez de le rappeler
[Musique]
il y a que des dames il y a que des
dames excusez-moi oui je sais c'est
mesdames
donc
je sais d'avancement de vos travaux et
je vais reprendre des éléments un petit
peu généraux et bien sûr je serai à
votre entière disposition pour répondre
aux questions plus précises ou pour
préciser certains points comme vous
l'avez fait remarquer madame la
Présidente dans la suite des débats
alors la question de la pénurie de
médicaments et pas une question récente
elle existe quasiment depuis depuis
toujours oserait se dire en tout cas en
tant que médecin hospitalier je l'ai
connu très régulièrement à des périodes
pas systématiquement l'hiver d'ailleurs
depuis un an la situation a été
particulièrement regardée
particulièrement regarder par une
meilleure un meilleur signalement de ces
risques de rupture et de pénurie par la
NSM qui s'est équipée des outils
nécessaires mais également avec des un
choc ou des chocs exogènes sur le
circuit du médicament et l'industrie du
médicament bien sûr la en Ukraine qui a
produit des difficultés principalement
dans les outils de conditionnement et
puis cette phase post covid qui a
complètement modifiée la la perception
que l'on pouvait avoir de de ces
consommations de médicaments avec une
période qui a été très concentrée sur
certains types de médicaments par
exemple paracétamol - sur d'autres les
antibiotiques puisque les mesures de
protection qui ont été prises avaient
diminué la prescription de ces mêmes
antibiotiques nous avons connu cet hiver
des difficultés importantes sur deux de
ces produits bien entendu le paracétamol
et l'amoxicilline principalement dans
leur forme pédiatrique on pourra venir
si vous le souhaitez sur ces sur ces
difficultés très particulières alors
quel a été la réaction que ce que j'ai
voulu mettre en place face à ces
pénuries vous l'avez dit madame la
Présidente une feuille de route pénurie
un plan pénurie avec un premier même
principe qui était l'établissement des
médicaments essentiels cette fameuse
liste publiée il y a deux jours pourquoi
publier une liste de ces médicaments
essentiels et bien pour mieux les
identifier mieux les surveiller mieux
les contrôler et identifier pour chacun
de ces médicaments réaliser une
cartographie des risques depuis la
production du principe actif jusqu'à la
distribution des boîtes en pharmacie je
pense qu'il est important ici de bien
souligner l'importance de ce dispositif
de cet éventail absolument complet en ce
qui concerne l'amoxicilline cet hiver
par exemple j'ai pu constater une une
différence entre des industriels me
disant que les stocks étaient là et
qu'ils arrivaient à produire et les
pharmaciens me disant au même moment
qu'ils n'arrivaient pas à avoir les
boîtes dans les pharmacies donc toutes
les toute cette chaîne de non seulement
de production mais également de
distribution est extrêmement importante
à prendre en compte
dans cette dans les mesures à prendre
bien entendu en dehors des mesures qui
ont été très
conjoncturelles cet hiver comme
les possibilités pour les pharmaciens de
distribuer que le nombre de comprimés
strictement nécessaire leur possibilité
des conditionnements des menus que nous
avons pu prendre refabrication au niveau
de pharmacie française de certains
produits actifs en dehors de ces mesures
immédiates bien entendu une stratégie de
relocalisation vous l'avez dit annoncé
il y a deux jours par le Président de la
République sur des principes actifs dans
la continuité de France relance et de
France 2030 et puis surtout une volonté
dans le cadre de ce plan de pénurique
d'information de transparence de clarté
envers nos concitoyens bien entendu mais
aussi envers les professionnels de santé
les invitants en cas de difficultés ou
de tension à aligner leur prescription
sur les molécules plus facilement
identifiables
parallèlement à cette stratégie mise en
place au niveau français bien sûr une
stratégie également au niveau européen
et j'ai eu l'occasion d'échanger à
plusieurs reprises avec mes homologues
européens le dernier réunion d'ailleurs
à Stockholm avec que pour seul sujet les
pénuries de médicaments au niveau de
l'Europe puisque cette problématique
bien entendu et le dépasse largement nos
frontières concernant l'Europe donc la
France c'est associé avec 18 autres pays
à une proposition de la Belgique le
critical medicins actes qui vise à
reporter sur ces médicaments essentiels
ce qui a été voté sur les métaux rares
qui sont considérés comme indispensables
cette stratégie est très proche de celle
de la France avec là aussi établissement
d'une liste de médicaments dit
essentiels réalisation mise en place
d'un principe de solidarité au niveau
européenne également d'une exigence de
transparence sur les production
vis-à-vis des industriels et une
stratégie de relocalisation de la
production de ses principes actifs et de
ses médicaments au niveau de l'Europe
donc vous voyez que le plan qui est
déployé et que j'ai lancé suite aux
difficultés de cet hiver et tout à fait
parallèle au plan européen et la
circuler avec lui pour que nous
puissions aboutir à cette souveraineté
sur sur l'ensemble des médicaments dit
essentiels vous interrogez sur la
réalisation de cette liste et
l'évolution un petit peu de cette liste
je crois que c'est important les les
tous premiers médicaments que nous avons
travaillé était issus uniquement ces 58
dont vous parliez étaient issus
uniquement de l'anesthésie réanimation
effectivement des travaux de la Société
française d'anesthésie réanimation que
nous avons souhaité
dupliquer sur l'ensemble des spécialités
c'est la une méthode qui est bien connue
dans le domaine médical qui est la
méthode Delphi qui consiste d'abord à
screener par un comité l'ensemble des
molécules qui sont utilisées par une
spécialité ensuite confier cette liste
un groupe d'experts un peu plus d'une
vingtaine de membres qui va permettre
d'identifier et de noter chacun de ces
médicaments en fonction de sa criticité
pour les patients en fonction également
de sa fréquence d'utilisation à l'issue
de laquelle cette liste ressort les
médicaments considérés essentiels pour
chaque spécialité nous avons
reproduit cette méthode pour l'ensemble
des spécialités ce qui aboutit à cette
liste finale de 450 médicaments pour
être très précis c'est une liste avec
400 médicaments plus 50 médicaments
considérés comme des médicaments de
santé publique en tout cas que nous
avons voulu mettre comme médicament de
santé publique en ce terme ce sont des
médicaments qui répondent à des
objectifs de santé publique par exemple
les vaccinations par exemple la pilule
abortive qui fait partie de cette liste
de médicaments
voilà comment nous sommes arrivés à
assez 450 c'est une stratégie qui n'est
qu'une stratégie médicale
faite par les professionnels de santé et
elle se combine avec une liste enfin en
tout cas une stratégie de fragilité
industrielle qui aboutit à cette liste
cœur dont parlait le président de la
République avec la volonté de
relocaliser la production d'une
cinquantaine de médicaments dont les 25
premiers ont été annoncés il y a deux
jours sur cette ces médicaments de cette
liste cœur
l'association les associations de
patients pardon vous en avez parlé ou
bien sûr être associé à l'élaboration
finale de cette liste comme j'ai eu
l'occasion de le lire c'est une liste
qui est vivante ce n'est pas une liste
qui est complètement complètement gravée
dans le dans le marbre les vivants en ce
sens où chaque interpellation pourra
être analysé selon la même méthode par
les spécialistes concernés pour nous
dire s'il y a lieu de rajouter un ou
deux médicaments dans cette liste et
enfin elle est vivante parce qu'il est
prévue d'ores et déjà de la mettre à
jour tous les ans pour suivre là aussi
les évolutions thérapeutiques et la
sortie d'éventuellement de nouveaux
médicaments
ma terre veut dire sur la bêta estine
donc c'est un effectivement un anti
vertigineux qui a un service médical
rendu qui est modéré qui ne fait pas
partie de la liste des médicaments index
thérapeutiques majeurs
cette fameuse liste là aussi une autre
liste on pourrait une liste de
400 de 6000 médicaments dont 400 ont été
là aussi identifiés de façon plus
précise mais pour des raisons de stock
donc c'est tout à fait tout à fait
différent il existe des alternatives
thérapeutiques tout à fait tout à fait
comparable à la bétaïstine selon la
Haute Autorité de Santé le temps gagné
par exemple donc de ce côté là ça fait
partie là aussi des des éléments de
réponse il y a-t-il des médicaments qui
peuvent les remplacer de façon tout à
fait transparente quand c'est le cas
effectivement la problématique et la
problématique et moi
très bien je vais tout de suite passer
la parole à Laurence Cohen rapporteur
pour une première série de questions
merci monsieur le ministre
alors merci merci monsieur le ministre
en fait je vais vous poser 6 questions à
peu près et après je laisserai mes
collègues prendre le relais et
éventuellement je vous demanderai des
précisions donc suite aux propos
liminaires de la présidence
effectivement vous nous avez déjà
apporté un certain nombre d'éléments
constituant la façon dont vous avez
travaillé sur la liste des 450
médicaments essentiels le dossier de
presse indique parmi ces 450 médicaments
essentiels 40%, ont connu des ruptures
dans les deux dernières années et vous
avez annoncé dans Le Parisien
mardi que les médicaments essentiels
devront avoir 4 mois de stock peut-être
même plus pour certains notamment ceux
qui ne sont fabriqués que dans une ou
deux usines alors est-ce qu'on doit
comprendre que l'ensemble des
médicaments essentiels
feront l'objet d'une obligation de
stocks renforcée portée à quatre mois
comme c'est déjà le cas me semble-t-il
de 422 mi TM à fort risque de rupture
donc ça c'est ma c'est ma première ma
première ma première question
parmi ces 450 médicaments 50 font
l'objet de mesures de relocalisation
dont la moitié à court terme d'après ce
cas annoncé d'ailleurs le président de
la République 25 verront leur production
relocalisée augmentée significativement
sur le territoire national 8 nouveaux
projets de rock de relocalisation
soutenu donc par l'État via France 2023
pour un investissement total de 160
millions d'euros il y a notamment le
midazolam amoxicilline et six autres
anticancéreux donc
160 160 millions d'euros sur la liste
des bénéficiaires se trouvent le
laboratoire GSK un laboratoire que l'on
connaît bien Niki a fait des bénéfices
en 2022 de 17 milliards d'euros donc
17 milliards d'euros
quelle aide vous allez apporter à ce
laboratoire et pensez-vous que c'est
indispensable pour rompre avec les
pénuries d'autant que quand on sait
qu'en 2020 pour par France relance il y
a eu à peu près 200 millions qui ont été
donnés à l'industrie pharmaceutique donc
cette politique sans contrepartie est-ce
qu'elle vous sent vraiment efficace je
le répète contenu des pénuries que nous
avons connues et que nous continuons de
connaître donc ma question c'est en fait
est-ce que vous envisagez
des conditionnalités par rapport à ces
aides qui sont données parce que depuis
30 ans les laboratoires ont délocalisé
les grands laboratoires pharmaceutiques
ont délocalisé aujourd'hui il y a une
volonté c'est très bien nous l'appuyons
de relocaliser en France en Europe mais
s'il y a pas de conditionnalités rien ne
garanti que dans quelques temps elle ne
repartiront pas c'est la première
question et surtout et surtout des
garanties par rapport aussi à l'emploi
parce que nous avons auditionné à deux
reprises le laboratoire Sanofi et nous
avons eu la confirmation hélas qu'il y
aurait une suppression de 135 postes
d'ici 2025 sur les sites d'Aramon
Mourenx et cisteron ce qui
s'accompagnerait selon les syndicats
d'une perte de production de plus de 50
tonnes de principes actifs donc vous
voyez ma question c'est vraiment
effectivement l'État at prend ses
responsabilités mais
quelle garantie vous avez que les grands
labos prennent les leurs pour ne pas se
retrouver dans une situation telle que
nous la connaissons telle que nous la
connaissons aujourd'hui
et puis mais peut-être mais j'arrête là
parce que les autres questions mes trois
autres questions sont sur les prix donc
peut-être qu'on peut je peux vous
laisser la parole là-dessus et puis
j'enchaînerai sur trois questions sur
les prix merci d'avance monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le ministre merci merci le
plaisir de leur rapporteur alors
première question elle pose elle porte
effectivement sur ces sur ce sujet de
stock ou pasteur pour revenir sur la
l'élaboration d'abord de cette liste des
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutique
majeur
issue de la loi santé de 2007 de 2016
avec un décret sur les stocks qui datent
de 2021 l'ensemble des médicaments de
cette liste sont concernés par des
stocks de deux mois et comme vous le
savez si sur cette l'ensemble de cette
liste il y a eu des difficultés et des
tensions dans les deux ans précédant ces
médicaments interviennent dans cette
autre liste plus restreinte de 400 avec
la nécessité de stocks de quatre mois de
là vient cette question des stocks de
quatre mois alors je ne vais pas
répondre aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble des
450 médicaments de la liste des
médicaments essentiels bien entendu la
constitution de stocks fait partie d'une
des réponses qui pourra être apportée à
l'issue de l'analyse de cette
cartographie des risques dont je vous
parlais en fonction là aussi des
capacités de production du fait de
savoir si nous sommes dépendants d'un
d'une deux trois plusieurs
usines ou pas la capacité de monter en
puissance cela va être étudié par pour
chaque chaque médicament de cette liste
de médicaments essentiels bien sûr dans
cette liste il y a une majorité de
médicaments qui sont déjà concernés par
ces stocks de 4 mois de la liste des
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutiques
majeurs il n'y a pas de décision ni de
choix ni de volonté de ma part de
rapporter ces quatre mois de stock sur
l'ensemble de la liste c'est pas du tout
l'essence de mes propos mais c'est une
des possibilités en fonction de
l'analyse de cette cartographie des
risques
concernant les mesures de de
relocalisation et en tout cas les
mesures qui ont été faites et vous
m'interpellier par rapport à GSK alors
concernant GSK il y a un investissement
déjà de l'industriel de 22 millions
d'euros et oui il y a pour l'ensemble de
ces entreprises des conditions
des conditions de
le contrôle un petit peu de leurs
engagements et par rapport aux sommes
que l'État pourra être amené à mettre en
place alors elles sont de deux grands
deux grands axes je ne pourrais
malheureusement pas entrer le dans le
détail qui font partie des contrats qui
sont encore discutés entreprises par
entreprise mais il y a un premier axe
qui est un axe sur un engagement de la
part de l'industriel sur des volumes
et volume à mettre à disposition du
marché français à l'horizon 2026
et la deuxième partie concernant les
conditions d'investissement par rapport
à ces engagements ça va être là aussi
des possibilités de de pénalité par
rapport à au non-respects d'engagement
industriels qui pourraient être pris que
ce soit sur les délais de mise en oeuvre
tout comme ces volumes dont je vous
parlais donc oui il y a des
inconditionnements qui est fait pour
chacun de ces contrats mais je ne
pourrais pas là entrer dans le détail de
contrat qui pour certains sont vous le
comprendrez bien encore en cours de
discussion
oui effectivement il y a des choses qui
qui rentrent dans dans le ce qu'on
appelle le secret des affaires
après il y a aussi comme vous êtes face
à une
commission d'enquête il y a des choses
que vous pouvez nous livrer par écrit et
qui ne seront pas effectivement donc
diffusé
j'aimerais quand même bien avoir plus de
précisions sur parce que quand vous
parlez des stocks
4 mois pas pour nous concernant pas tous
les tous les médicaments monsieur le
ministre je tiens quand même à attirer
votre attention le Sénat avait voté à la
nécessité de porter les stocks à à
quatre mois et ça n'avait pas tenu
face au gouvernement qui avait ramené à
deux mois donc j'attire votre attention
sur cette contradiction apparente
voilà il s'agit quand même
de bien mesurer les tenants les
aboutissants les conséquences et puis
effectivement quand on dit stock de 4
mois ça veut dire aussi la possibilité
de stocker parce que c'est quand même ça
demande aussi un grand volume donc ça
demande une anticipation ça ma première
remarque deuxième remarque concernant
les conditionnalités je suis ravie que
vous eniez
mais je suis un petit peu dubitative sur
le côté un peu vague de ces
conditionnalités parce que vous n'avez
pas répondu concernant les emplois or ce
sont des savoir-faire qui sont qui sont
bradés quand on quand on quand on se
sépare de personnel c'est ma première
remarque et donc je pense qu'il faut
être attentif à ça sur les pénalités on
a vu qu'il y a des pénalités qui
existent déjà de par la loi quels sont
trop peu exigeantes je veux dire comme
ça et qu'en tout cas c'est l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament qui
fait ce qu'elle peut contenu de ses
moyens humain et il y a très peu de
comment dirais-je de sanctions qui
tombent je crois qu'il y en a eu trois
si je me trompe pas en 2022 qu'en plus
la publicité alors ça c'est aussi
quelque chose qui est quand même assez
incroyable la publicité concernant
effectivement les pénalités infligées à
tel ou tel grand labo ne reste qu'un
mois sur le site de l'Agence nationale
de sécurité du médicament donc vous
voyez il faut savoir que le labo était
sanctionné il faut savoir à quel moment
ça tombe il faut aller voir donc si on
pense que c'est dissuasif il faut être
plus exigeant ça c'est ma remarque Par
rapport effectivement
aux questions que je vous avais posées
pour avoir un peu plus de précision
monsieur monsieur le ministre concernant
les prix
on a été beaucoup au niveau de notre
commission
d'enquête alerté par finalement ce qui
serait une insuffisance des prix trop
bas notamment pour les médicaments
anciens mais avec une vraie
contradiction monsieur le ministre
puisque on nous dit que que ce sont les
prix qui font que
il y aurait une pénurie ce serait une
cause de pénurie parce que quand même
les pénuries touchent les les
médicaments anciens mais pas les
produits innovants qui s'envolent à des
prix
exorbitants pour ne pas dire scandaleux
donc mais en même temps on voit que nos
voisins je pense par exemple à la Suisse
mais il y a d'autres exemples qui ont
des prix bien plus importants sur les
médicaments ont vécu les mêmes pénuries
donc les prix ne seraient pas ne sont
pas ne peuvent pas être la seule la
seule condition alors je sais que vous
avez vous avez prévu d'abord il y a eu
un moratoire
et il y a eu il était prévu que
finalement il y ait également une hausse
des prix mais là encore que ça se fasse
en contrepartie d'engagement des
industriels sur une sécurisation de
l'approvisionnement du marché français
donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous
préciser ces engagements et comment vous
allez vous assurer que les industriels
donc respectent ce que vous leur
demandez
et quand on a parlé des prix il y a
aussi beaucoup de nos interlocuteurs qui
nous ont parlé de la clause de
sauvegarde la clause de sauvegarde qui
est au départ devait être s'appliquée
uniquement aux produits
aux produits qui n'étaient pas innovants
on va dire et aujourd'hui qui a un champ
beaucoup beaucoup plus large et ce qui
nous a été dit c'est que c'était surtout
le caractère imprévisible qui qui
portait finalement un coup ou des
difficultés à un certain nombre à un
certain nombre d'entreprises donc est-ce
qu'on ne doit pas réformer cette clause
de sauvegarde et notamment je pense
est-ce que vous êtes absolument persuadé
que il y a une vraie différence
dans l'application de cette clause de
sauvegarde entre ce qu'on appelle les
Big Pharma et les PME parce que ce sont
des entreprises de nature de nature
enfin ma dernière question monsieur le
ministre c'est que lors de la crise de
la
covid-19
les pharmacies à usage intérieures les
pays et la GEP ce sont mobilisés pour
faire face à l'explosion de la demande
et notamment de la demande de cura et je
pense aux
c'est grâce à ces structures publiques
que le système de santé a finalement pu
faire face aux besoins des malades de la
covid notamment en réanimation donc on
voit bien là qu'il y a un vrai
savoir-faire qui avéré et donc je pense
qu'il serait tout à fait regrettable de
s'en priver donc ça va m'amener à vous
poser deux questions monsieur le
ministre la première c'est que c'est
l'application de l'article 62 de la loi
LFSS c'est-à-dire la loi de finances de
la sécurité sociale 2022 sur les
préparations hospitalières spéciales en
vous demandant très concrètement quand
sortira le décret qui est nécessaire à
la mise en oeuvre de ce dispositif et
pourquoi il tarde tant et ma deuxième
question parce que je pense que là on
voit quand même que que le il faut il
faut modifier une autre notre notre
système économique du médicament et il
faut que l'État est la possibilité
d'avoir quelque part des contre-pouvoirs
importants et peut-être réinvestir une
production publique pour une part de
médicaments
pourquoi pas les 50 que vous avez mis en
exergue et du coup ma question c'est que
on pourrait s'appuyer sur la GEPS qui a
un vrai savoir-faire mais qui
aujourd'hui est dans l'incapacité de
fabriquer parce qu'on lui retire les
moyens et lors de l'audition de la GEPS
et bien nous avons eu la confirmation
qu'à leur qu'actuellement ils sont 120
ce qui est pas beaucoup et bien ils vont
voir une suppression de 40 à 50
ETP donc qu'est-ce que vous pensez faire
monsieur le ministre pour pour endiguer
ce phénomène parce que ça serait quand
même un moyen intéressant pour l'État
d'avoir pour des médicaments extrêmement
critiques la possibilité donc de faire
en sorte que tout de suite y essaie de
production c'est ce qu'ils ont prouvé
pendant la crise de la covid je vous
remercie
monsieur le ministre
merci
ma Présidente je vais essayer de
reprendre l'ensemble de
de vos remarques très riches questions
alors concernant les concernant les
stocks alors effectivement la
constitution de stock déjà c'est la
responsabilité de l'industriel c'est à
l'industriel que nous demandons de
réaliser des stocks dans un premier
temps et je ne parle pas ici de nos
stocks stratégiques bien entendu on ne
travaille pas que sur la constitution
des stocks mais on travaille également
sur les augmentations de de capacité de
production du produit donc ça c'est un
c'est un premier point je rappelle bien
par rapport au stock 4 mois dont on
parlait tout à l'heure c'est bien
lorsqu'il y a eu dans les deux ans
précédant une pénurie une tension sur
sur ce médicament c'est donc là aussi
quelque chose qui est dynamique dans le
temps qui peut bien sûr évoluer sur des
produits où on pourrait avoir ce genre
de difficulté je vous disais tout à
l'heure que nous travaillons main dans
la main avec l'Europe sur ces sujets de
pénurie de médicaments et là aussi il y
a des réflexions en cours travaux en
cours mais plus que des réflexions sur
des capacités de stockage à l'échelle
européenne et en ce sens nous
travaillons avec
era au niveau européen pour voir comment
on complète des stocks qui pourraient
être nationaux avec des stocks au niveau
européen le meilleur exemple de ce
travail à ras avec era bien sûr été dans
la les stocks de vaccins covid pendant
la pendant la pandémie
concernant votre votre question sur les
sanctions et la publicité entre
guillemets qui est fait sur sur ces
pénalités
j'entends j'entends bien sûr votre votre
remarque permettrait de renvoyer un peu
la question à la NSM que vous allez
recevoir tout à l'heure sur la
possibilité de maintenir plus longtemps
à l'information sur leur site pour pas
que ce soit un problème majeur en tout
cas si si la commission juge que cela
est nécessaire
c'est un décret sur la publication bon
on va voir ça fera donc une réponse
écrite il y a pas de problème sur ce
sujet
concernant le prix alors ça c'est
effectivement quelque chose qui revient
qui revient très régulièrement c'était
un sujet qui est qui est
particulièrement complexe je vous
remercie d'avoir relevé et que même la
Suisse qui paye les médicaments plus
chers que nous en tout cas en prix
faciale a eu des difficultés en fait des
difficultés touchent tous les pays y
compris l'Allemagne comme souvent en
parallèle avec la France pour le prix
sujet complexe parce que le prix facial
n'est pas le réel prix payé par par un
pays pour ces médicaments on prend bien
qu'il y a plusieurs éléments qui entrent
en ligne en ligne de compte il y a aussi
la
l'équilibre qu'il doit y avoir entre le
prix et les volumes bien entendu ce qui
explique que des coûts qui paraissent
extrêmement élevés pour des produits
très innovants qui sont aussi des
produits qui touchent qui touchent moins
de moins de patients et qui touche donc
qui ont sur un rapport prix volume qui
est tout à fait tout à fait différent
concernant l'ensemble de la réflexion
sur les prix et le sujet de cette clause
de sauvegarde alors la clause de
sauvegarde vous le savez est une clause
qui se déclenche au delà d'un certain
bénéfice qui avait été défini et annoncé
par le président de la République dans
le cadre du 6 et qui était de 2,4%. donc
il y a une assurance une garantie déjà
de bénéfices pour les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques et sa clause de
sauvegarde de se déclenche qu'après
alors effectivement il y a eu des
réflexions par rapport à la clause de
sauvegarde et des critiques importantes
au niveau de
ce mode de calcul qui ont amené la
première ministre à mettre en place un
groupe de travail autour d'elle qui doit
rendre ses conclusions
fin juin début juillet normalement sur
des des pistes pour revoir cette
politique d'attribution de prix du
médicament dans notre dans notre pays il
faut voir aussi que en ce qui concerne
cette un équilibre que je dois que je
dois maintenir bien entendu entre la
mise à disposition de ces médicaments
pour nos concitoyens et le prix auquel
nous sommes prêts à payer ces
médicaments dans l'équilibre que vous
connaissez bien de l'ONDAM et qui doit
prendre en compte l'ensemble de ces de
ces éléments
concernant le moratoire dont vous avez
parlé sur les produits les plus matures
en particulier les produits génériques
devant les remarques qui ont été faites
au moment de la mise en application de
cette courbe de sauvegarde cette année
nous avons décidé de bloquer le prix des
médicaments générés en tout cas de ne
plus le diminuer comme c'était le cas
effectivement il y avait un équilibre en
permanence à trouver entre des prix des
médicaments innovants très chers et des
médicaments plus anciens sur lequel on
pouvait diminuer le prix plus de baisse
pour l'instant de sur ces médicaments
génériques avec
l'interpellation entre guillemets des
industriels en leur disant et j'étais
avec mon collègue Roland Lescure à cette
occasion amenez-nous des éléments de
transparence pour voir quel est le réel
prix de production de vos de vos de ses
médicaments matures génériques et bien
entendu si le prix de production de
façon tout à fait transparente et
supérieure au prix auquel on achète vos
médicaments nous serons prêts à
envisager la hausse pour bien sûr
maintenir ces médicaments dans notre
marché
aujourd'hui j'ai toujours cet appel
envers les industriels et j'attends que
les dossiers remontent pour faire cette
équilibre de prix il y a eu des demandes
de réévaluation de prix pour un certain
nombre de médicaments il y en a très
régulièrement qui sont étudiés par le
CPS pour l'instant il n'y a pas eu de
réponse pour aller dans un sens ou dans
un autre
alors vous parlez aussi des pays et de
ce qui a été mis en place il faut que je
retrouve un petit peu tout ça alors le
concernant le décret puisque c'est de
celui-là pour le coup il y a pas de pas
d'inquiétude le décret est
au ministère actuellement en fin de
concertation ce sera fait à la fin du
mois
il a ensuite le décret à notifié au
niveau de l'Europe puisque tout ce qui
se passe au niveau médicament remonte
également au niveau européen qui a un
délai de trois mois pour nous donner son
avis et approuvé ce qui entraînera une
parution du décret normalement si on
fait bien le planning et on le fera bien
en octobre
en tout cas pour sa partie concernant
mon ministère le sujet le sujet est
réglé
alors sous la situation l'Ajax bon bien
sûr le savoir-faire vous en avez vous en
avez parlé il est particulièrement
essentiel à maintenir et on a vu sur sur
le cura mais aussi sur les
principes actifs sur l'amoxicilline donc
je me souvienne on a redemandé également
j'ai besoin de mettre en place je ne
peux pas vous apporter de réponse là
immédiate sur le nombre d'emplois mais
je vous apporterai là aussi une réponse
par écrit
[Musique]
je voudrais revenir sur des questions
qui ont été posées par ma collègue
Laurence Cohen en particulier sur le
problème des relocalisations et de
l'aide que l'on apporte dans ce dans ce
plan de relocalisation à des Big Pharma
qui jusqu'à présent ont été les
premières j'allais dire
les Big Pharma date des années 90 mais
qui ont été les premières à délocaliser
pour des problèmes de de coûts et de
bénéfices plus importants
des conditions RSE donc je trouve un
petit peu choquant qu'on aide
effectivement laboratoire comme GSK où
Sanofi Laurence laby on les a interrogé
à deux reprises et alors qu'on les avait
vu la veille de l'annonce de
licenciement de sang plus de 100
personnes ils nous ont la directrice ne
savait rien et puis c'était dans la
presse dès le lendemain donc la
transparence au niveau de ces de ces
bicarma est quand même quelque chose
d'important donc quelle est la force
qu'on peut avoir en tant qu'État pour
imposer
quelle est la force en tant que
gouvernement donc état pour imposer des
conditionnalités importantes si tantée
qu'on doit aider si tenter qu'on doit
aider des bicarma il me semble moi plus
logique d'aider des PME françaises qui
pourraient
entreprendre ces productions et donc
quelle est la force que l'on vous pouvez
avoir en particulier sur je reviens sur
les normes RSE qui me paraissent à moi
fondamentale tant surnom donc social
environnemental et je voudrais revenir
aussi sur la production publique
Laurence a osait parler de la GEPS et
je suis allé pour ma part voir la
famille centrale de de mon CHU qui
augmente du covid à produit
effectivement le curare et pour avoir
discuté avec le pharmacien en chef donc
de la pluie
il convient
de penser que on puisse sur certains
produits alors ils vont on va pas
remplacer effectivement toute la
production
pharmaceutique personne n'y pense et
ce serait pur folique de penser ça mais
est-ce qu'on a pas un certain nombre de
produits on a des capacités dans la
pharmacie centrale et sur le curare il y
a eu 4 sites qui ont été capables de
produire au moment de la crise du covid
ce qu'on peut pas envisager d'avoir une
production plus importante publique pour
certaines molécules je repense aussi
avoir eu un audition MK c'était il y a
deux ans à peu près qui me paraît alors
je me souviens plus maintenant du
produit d'un produit qu'on utilise un
hématologie en cancéro hémato qui était
fabriqué par par les pays qui a été
repris par le j'allais dire par un
laboratoire privé et qui coûte 10 fois
ou 20 fois je me souviens plus
exactement le prix de ce goûter quand il
était produit par la parmi centrale des
hôpitaux donc
serait selon moi une bonne façon d'agir
non seulement sur la production mais
aussi sur les prix de revient et en
particulier pour les hôpitaux parce que
les hôpitaux aujourd'hui sont tenus dans
une espèce de contradiction avec les
marchés publics où ils vont bien sûr
chercher compte tenu du je dirais de la
faiblesse de lambda ils vont chercher
les prix les moins les moins élevés et
donc le favorise pas obligatoirement de
la production française puisque ils
cherchent des prix les plus bas pour
pouvoir tenir leur budget et c'est
normal que les directeurs d'hôpitaux et
envie de tenir leur budget et donc leur
marché le marché public faut un petit
peu la donne voilà
[Musique]
ok moi je vais je vais compléter par
d'abord rebondir sur la question
industrielle après j'aurai une autre
série de questions mais d'abord pour
permettre les réponses dans un premier
temps je suis une question les
laboratoires qui sont donc accompagnés
dans le cadre de la roula localisation
sont des laboratoires qui ont été
repérés pour produire des médicaments
qui ont été en pénurie voire en tension
en tout cas qui sont dans une situation
industrielle particulièrement fragile
les nombreuses auditions montré que dans
les situations de pngrid il y avait des
arbitrages de répartition des stocks pas
toujours au bénéfice de la France ce
sont les mêmes labos qui vont être
accompagnés pour reproduire en France
est-ce que d'ici 2026 dans les
contraintes qui sont proposées il est
proposé que des stocks particuliers soit
de nouveau destinés comme ça aurait dû
l'être d'ailleurs
à la France dans la production de ces
fameux laboratoires voilà c'est ce que
je voulais vous poser comme question
dans un premier temps sur les questions
industrielles
merci je me permettrai d'avoir de
répondre à votre dernière question
puisque la réponse sera peut-être un peu
plus clair
les arbitrages bien sûr ont été faits
alors pas toujours au bénéfice de la
France effectivement en tout cas c'était
la ça pouvait être la tentation ce qui
m'a amené à prendre des décisions cet
hiver pour interdire justement que soit
grossiste d'ailleurs que ce soit
également laboratoire qui produit en
France d'exporter les produits dont nous
manquions vers d'autres d'autres pays
c'est un des éléments vous en vous en
parliez tout à l'heure du plan blanc une
des décisions qu'on peut prendre de
façon de façon immédiate l'interdiction
de cette exportation vers d'autres vers
d'autres pays
concernant alors toute la question la
question industrielle je pourrais pas
forcément vous répondre à tout puisque
certaines d'un de ces sujets concernent
plus mon collègue de l'industrie que moi
bien entendu je cherche pas à passer le
ballon systématiquement à Roland Lescure
mais en tout cas tout ce qui concerne
les les engagements également des sujets
de sur la clause d'environnementale et
des productions des productions vertes
qui sont qui sont en France et qui
peuvent également jouer sur sur le prix
la transparence c'est vraiment l'élément
clé dans ce dans ce sujet et en tout cas
c'est l'élément qui est demandé de façon
systématique lorsque il y a des sujets
de tension sur les médicaments et de
relocalisation de relocalisation en
France
vous parliez de ces Big Pharma traite de
dire pas que nous étions il y a deux
jours en Ardèche au laboratoire
Aguettant donc qui est qui est un
laboratoire français cette petite
laboratoire certes mais laboratoire avec
lequel nous avons pu travailler avec mon
collègue Roland Lescure pour qu'il
puisse reprendre l'usine carlite dans le
nord de la France qui fabriquait des
poches à perfusion donc on voit que nos
industries françaises sont aussi
extrêmement dynamiques sur le secteur et
avec dans cette dans cette usine de
champagne en Ardèche des capacités de
production qui sont des multipliés c'est
ça aussi le sujet de la relocalisation
c'est aussi augmenter les capacités de
production d'entreprises qui sont déjà
sur place et nous avons pu voir une
chaîne de production qui est qui est en
test actuellement et aussi ces
entreprises qui sont extrêmement agiles
et qui ont la possibilité en quelques
heures de changer de produit de leur
chaîne de production dès lors qu'il y a
du principe actif qui est disponible
concernant les les hôpitaux et les
marchés publics la propension
effectivement à aller chercher des prix
des prix qui sont moins élevés ailleurs
alors
là les les coûts qui sont qui sont qui
sont mis entre guillemets sur la table
pour les hôpitaux sont souvent
supérieurs bien sûr au coût au coût par
l'industrie quand la production est
faite par les hôpitaux
si on prend l'ensemble de la chaîne
c'est à dire pas uniquement le principe
actif et on fabrique les gélules ou en
fabrique etc d'ailleurs pour la petite
histoire ma maman est en pharmacienne
quand j'étais jeune j'ai participé à la
fabrication des gélules sur ces ces
carrés sur lesquels on décalé des élus
en tout cas bon les coudes de production
dans nos dans nos pays dans nos
pharmacies dans nos hôpitaux restent
quand même plus élevés que les coups de
l'industrie c'est plutôt des solutions
supplémentaires là aussi dans le cadre
dans le cadre du plan blanc
les réflexions sur la production
publique et sur la GEP en particulier
alors lajep ça un rôle certes de
production l'intérêt est aussi de les
faire avancer vers un rôle de
coordonnateur sur l'ensemble des
productions possibles vous le disiez
très bien que ce soit au niveau des
pharmacies d'officine des pays voir de
certains sous-traitants pour adapter
notre marché de production et puis la
réflexion sur ces production publique et
elle se fait en tout cas moi je souhaite
qu'elle s'oriente aussi vers des
molécules abandonnées par certains
laboratoires on voit bien qu'il y a des
molécules très matures qui peuvent
peut-être abandonnés par les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques pour des
raisons de rentabilité et c'est surtout
là je pense que nous avons un rôle à
jouer en tant que en tant que puissance
publique
voilà je pense que j'ai à peu près
toujours cette question je vous en
parlais tout à l'heure d'équilibre à
avoir entre la mise à disposition des
médicaments et le coût à payer qui doit
être le plus juste possible même si il
est défi difficile de définir ce qu'est
un coût juste
merci Monsieur le Ministre donc je vais
je vais rebondir sur vos propos
improductifs
je vous avais posé la question du
contenu du plan blanc donc quels sont
les mesures
tout le moins celles qui ont été
arbitrées mais
logiquement ça devrait être des pas loin
d'être le cas a priori
sur la question des stocks et du fameux
quatre mois on a vu que même pour de moi
c'était le sujet actuel c'est qui
contrôle et est-ce que c'est on sera
exclusivement sur du déclaratif voilà
parce que c'est on a bien vu que
les laboratoires ont été régulièrement
mis en défaut sur ce sujet
parce que faute de contrôle on ne peut
pas
vérifier l'exactitude de des stocks donc
on passe de 2 à 4 mois j'allais dire
c'est certes c'est une grosse avancée
mais si les stocks sont pas vérifiés on
avancera pas beaucoup plus en tout cas
sur les mêmes médicaments qui sont en
situation de pénurie et notamment parce
que la balle se renvoie entre le
laboratoire le grossiste répartiteur et
donc il y a un espèce de flou sur qui
est responsable de quoi et donc est-ce
que vis-à-vis des grossistes respirats
répartiteurs les stocks seront également
contrôler ou est-ce que des exigences
seront demandées
concernant la contractualisation donc
[Musique]
il me semble pour des raisons de
transparence avec les entreprises de
relocalisation
il me semble que pour des raisons de
transparence la question des règles
communes qui vont être exigées quand
même ce qui peut y avoir des règles
communes on est sur évidemment des
médicaments différents des étapes de
fabrication un peu différentes et il
n'empêche qu'on est face à la situation
de médicaments et les règles doivent
être les mêmes sur un certain nombre de
sujets donc est-ce qu'il est prévu
d'avoir un espèce de de vademekum des
règles communes
à la fois apporté par votre ministère et
aussi par celui de de
l'industrie et de l'économie de façon à
ce qu'on puisse au moins connaître
l'exigence minimale qui est demandé en
cas d'accompagnement massif massif de
l'industrie
même si c'est pour de la
industrialisation fut-elle à destination
de médicaments ma troisième question
porte sur la question des tensions et
des pénuries parce que vous êtes médecin
vous savez bien
vous avez certainement vécu cette
situation de la tension c'est à dire
10 passions ont besoin d'un médicament
il y a le traitement que pour 5
et donc ça veut dire que pour 5 il y a
une pénurie et donc avez-vous des
propositions à faire sur ce sujet des
tensions c'est dire l'amour parce qu'au
moment de la pénurie le temps qu'on le
temps qu'on inonde à nouveau le marché
il se passe un petit peu de temps on l'a
bien vécu à plusieurs reprises et donc
cette question de la tension et du délai
raisonnable enfin vous considérez comme
étant raisonnable ou utile de façon à
alerter à mettre en place un certain
nombre d'obligations ma quatrième
question c'est le coût des pénuries
parce que alors là honnêtement le coup
des pénuries on nous parle beaucoup du
du
PLFSS évidemment de la ligne de mandat
etc mais le coût des pénuries c'est une
réalité vous savez très bien quand un
appel d'offres hospitalier et ton site
sur un médicament particulier en
situation de pénurie on négocier avec un
autre laboratoire et donc c'est un coût
plus important là nous a répondu que
c'était la ligne hospitalière donc
c'était pas la ligne médicament enfin
tout un tas de sujets de ce genre que
les médicaments quand ils sont remplacés
par des BIOS similaires ou des
équivalents très très fréquemment le
médicament de remplacement est plus
coûteux que le médicament d'origine et
puis j'allais dire il y a les cousins
directs c'est les coûts en matière de
santé et de prise en charge sanitaire
qui sont pas forcément des coûts de
médicaments encore qui peuvent l'être
mais c'est le retard à la prise en
charge ça en tout cas c'est plus coûteux
du point de vue thérapeutique en
cancérologie nul doute là-dessus les
renoncements à traitement parce que les
patients trouvent que c'est trop
compliqué et les renoncements aussi ont
un coût en matière de santé un coût
sonore est trébuchant et donc en fait
dans cette question de la pénurie les
relations du coût de la pénurie n'est
jamais mis en avant et on regarde on
parle de la ligne du PLFSS et de
médicaments et du prix du médicament et
donc je pense que c'est un des éléments
d'arbitrage qu'il serait nécessaire
d'avoir et
peut-être qu'on est une estimation en
tout cas à partir du moment où on parle
le coup de la santé il me semble que
celle-là celui-là est particulièrement
essentiel et puis mon dernier sujet
porte sur les appels d'offres
hospitalier on nous dit que on
favoriserait un petit peu plus désormais
les fabrications européennes ou
française
quand on a visité séquence par exemple
il nous a bien été précisé que fabriqué
en France certes mais si on commande pas
en France et notamment par la voix
hospitalière ou par la voix d'ailleurs
des commandes communes et groupées des
cliniques privées parce qu'il y a des
groupements de commandes pour les
cliniques privées également pour le coup
évidemment il faut bien vendre les
produits et donc si c'est pas
commandé en France les produits iront
ailleurs je vous remercie
[Musique]
pour me dit justement où les industriels
feraient marron et justifieront de
produire ailleurs
oui merci madame la Présidente
dans l'ordre vos différentes questions
alors concernant le plan blanc alors
pourquoi plan blanc
hospitalier ça parle ça parle en tout
cas au professionnel de santé le
principe de ce plan n'est pas un
principe que comme tout plan si on le
veut opérationnel
de listing de choses à faire dans
l'ordre si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
c'est-à-dire le principe du
déclenchement d'un plan et en
particulier d'un plan blanc c'est
lorsque toutes les mesures précédentes
n'ont pas pu être efficaces ou lorsque
nous sommes face à une situation qui
était imprévisible si la situation est
prévisible on n'est plus dans le cadre
d'un plan blanc on est dans le cadre de
cette cartographie des risques dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure
titre d'exemple
l'incendie d'une usine ou d'une chaîne
de production c'est typiquement quelque
chose qui est qui est pas qui est pas
envisageable des problèmes comme je vous
disais tout à l'heure de choquer exogène
la guerre du crâne c'est pas forcément
quelque chose qu'on peut qu'on peut
prédire donc le principe de plan blanc
c'est d'avoir une un listing d'action et
qui va nous permettre en cas de
difficulté d'aller piocher dans ces
différentes actions pour les adapter à
la situation alors ce listing d'action
il est il est extrêmement extrêmement
vaste il peut agir comme je disais tout
à l'heure est-ce que nous avons fait cet
hiver il peut agir sur la dispensation
par le pharmacien lui permettre de
déconditionner les boîtes de médicaments
pour ne donner que la partie strictement
nécessaire il peut agir aussi sur la
récupération et vous avez vu dans le cas
du bon usage des médicaments la campagne
lancée par santé publique France
actuellement donc sur l'ensemble de ce
bon usage par nos concitoyens il y a
également des mesures qui concernent les
professionnels mesure concernant les
professionnels pour afficher clairement
des
et pousser vers l'utilisation de
produits équivalents si je peins par
exemple de l'amoxicilline qui est un
antibiotique qui est extrêmement
prescrit il existe des classes
thérapeutiques équivalentes et qui
peuvent être utilisés en cas de en cas
de pénurie on parlait tout à l'heure de
la production en France que ce soit dans
nos pays ou que ce soit dans les
officines tout ça fait partie un petit
peu de ces mesures du plan blanc nous
sommes en train de finaliser et qui
seront disponibles au niveau du mois de
juillet pour ce qui est de la feuille de
route pénurie donc c'est bien il faut il
faut pas s'attendre si je peux me
permettre dans ce plan blanc d'avoir un
petit un je fais cela petit deux je fais
cela etc non c'est vraiment un paquet de
solutions et d'outils que l'on doit
adapter à chaque situation je leur ai
dit si les situations sont prévisibles
on a effectivement ces fiches de
réaction le plan blanc c'est tout ce
qu'on peut mettre en oeuvre pour
répondre à une situation imprévue alors
là je vous parle du plan blanc hivernal
puisque c'est celui qui était annoncé
voilà c'était celui-là dont je vous
parlais il y a deux
c'est pas exactement ça si je peux me
permettre la présidente le plan blanc
le plan blanc est de façon tout à fait
globale et va être bien sûr concentré
sur ces médicaments essentiels vous
l'avez bien compris par contre il y a on
a appris un plan hivernal pourquoi un
plan hivernal parce que tous les hivers
il y a les mêmes pathologies tous les
hivers on va avoir besoin de paracétamol
on va avoir besoin d'antibiotiques et
c'est donc de se cibler sur ces produits
et de corticoïdes également c'est pour
se cibler sur sur ces produits et là de
façon très précise voire quelles sont
les capacités déjà de des industriels à
nous fournir le volume et le volume
pas uniquement évalué sur les
consommations de l'année précédente je
pense que dans différents entretiens
bien expliqué les difficultés que nous
avons eu ça a été ce décrochage entre la
demande 13% le paracétamol par rapport à
la consommation de l'année précédente
donc la nécessité là aussi pour les
industriels et l'ont bien compris
d'avoir des anticipations de volume
glissées sur les années précédentes et
pas uniquement sur sur la sur la
dernière année donc là c'est très
spécifique sur les médicaments de
l'hiver alors en ce qui concerne aussi
sur sur ce bon usage et ça répond en
même temps aux questions que vous
portiez sur la sur la tension quand il y
a du patients et qu'on ne peut en
traiter que que 5 la question elle est
vraiment l'action le plus en amont
possible et la diffusion extrêmement
large de l'information je crois que
c'est ça qui est la transparence elle
doit être aussi pour nous vis-à-vis des
professionnels de santé et vis-à-vis nos
concitoyens parce que lorsqu'on peut
signifier un professionnel de santé qui
dit à une tension donc avant ces
ruptures qu'il a une tension sur un
antibiotique il va très naturellement en
prescrira d'une autre classe pour la
même efficacité pour le patient je crois
que c'est très très important d'agir en
amont les antibiotiques sont un bon
exemple vous le savez la France est
très prescripteur d'antibiotiques en
moyenne plus que les autres des autres
pays européens et le bon exemple sur
cette question de tension et de bon
usage c'est par exemple sur l'angine
avec l'utilisation de la aussi vendue
possible pour les pharmaciens d'utiliser
des trodes ces tests qui permettent de
vérifier que effectivement le patient a
bien besoin d'antibiotiques et ce qui
permettra aux pharmaciens de ne pas lui
en donner donc tout ce qui concerne le
bon usage la bonne prescription c'est
extrêmement important en termes
d'information sur
surtout ça quel est le point commun
finalement sur cette information et je
rejoins également ce que vous disiez sur
le contrôle des stocks qui effectivement
sont un sujet
déclaratif aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin davantage de contrôle
non seulement sur les stocks des
industriels mais sur des stocks des
grossistes répartiteurs c'est tout
l'enjeu du système d'information qui est
en train de se déployer vous savez que
maintenant chaque boîte de médicaments
est identifiée à titre individuel ce qui
nous permet en théorie de suivre toute
son tout son cheminement dans la chaîne
et le sujet de l'amélioration du système
d'information fait partie d'ailleurs de
la feuille de route pénurie
vous parlez d'avoir des règles un
vademecom de ces règles et de ses
exigences minimales vous avez raison
extrêmement pertinent il n'existe pas
aujourd'hui mais nous allons nous allons
regrouper déjà les règles qui existent
et je vais voir avec mon collègue de
l'industrie ce que l'on peut mettre dans
ce bas des macum qui ne soit pas en
contradiction là aussi avec le secret
des affaires et directs principes mais
je prends je prends l'idée d'une fin
d'une manière générale sur ce bas des
méca
sur le coup des pénuries
le cou des pénuries
manifestement c'est un sujet c'est
compliqué de répondre
oui c'est en même temps on est une
approche terriblement comptable de la
santé en France donc ça mériterait
d'être gardé avec attention alors ça
mérite et vous avez bien sûr entièrement
raison d'être gardé avec avec attention
le coût des
renégociations effectivement quelque
chose qui est identifiable
malheureusement je crains que le reste
des coûts dont vous parliez et pour
l'instant extrêmement difficile à
évaluer c'est complexe et
multifactoriels quel est le coût on l'a
bien vu pendant la crise de covid
comment évalue-t-on le coût d'un
traitement qui a été retardé ou d'une
intervention qui a été retardée donc là
on serait potentiellement dans un
traitement qui aurait pu être retardé
pour un patient de quelques jours de
quelques semaines ça me semble très
difficile d'évaluer le coût réel donc le
coût qui est qui est visible c'est le
coup de éventuellement c'est
renégociations en tout cas le coût
hospitalier vous en avez parlé celui-ci
est
identifiable j'ai pas de chiffres à vous
donner là mais on regardera si on peut
l'approcher au plus près par contre tous
les coups indirects dont vous parliez
j'ai peur que ce soit extrêmement
extrêmement difficile
c'est difficile mais je pense que ça
mériterait d'être gardé peut-être sur
une corde de suivi
scientifiquement il me semble que c'est
possible
on va regarder c'est pas parce que c'est
compliqué que c'est impossible vous avez
raison Madame la Présidente on va
regarder ce qu'on peut faire ça me
permet juste de rappeler ou bien
également un élément par rapport au coût
de ces pénuries au coup de ses tensions
l'objectif vous l'avez bien compris
c'est de ne pas arriver à cette
situation de mettre tout ce qu'il faut
en amont pour ne pas arriver à cette
situation j'ai oublié absolument excusé
d'exprimer un élément qui qui est
essentiel et qui en plus fait partie du
titre non ministère qui est la
prévention bien entendu la meilleure
façon de ne pas avoir besoin de
médicaments c'est de ne pas être malade
et toute la politique de prévention que
nous continuons à mettre en place je
pense en particulier au vaccination la
vaccination papillomavirus et aussi dans
cet objectif de lutter contre les
pénuries
et sur les appels d'offres
sur la commande publique en quelque
sorte
[Musique]
parce que les industriels nous ont
vraiment évoqué le fait que il
produisait et puis il y avait pas de
commande on est allés voir euro happy
euro happy il y a de la fabrication
quand même importante c'était une
découverte parce qu'on nous parle
toujours des principes actifs fabriqués
ailleurs et puis là hop les corticoïdes
sont fabriqués à Euro happy mais en fait
ils alors qu'on était en pleine phase
pénurie par rapport à un certain nombre
de corticoïdes or il n'était pas en
charge pleine de production parce qu'il
n'y avait pas de commande et un des
leviers c'est la commande publique
hospitalière mais on a un autre levier
quand même c'est la commande via le
système hospitalier privé puisque
désormais ce sont des grandes des grands
groupes qui qui font des appels d'offres
communs et donc ça pourrait être un
outil quand même de sécurisation de
consommation de la production mais de
sécurisation de la production aussi dans
le territoire
je vais passer une la parole à Patricia
chez linger
ministre j'aimerais venir sur la pénurie
de médicaments concernant la pédiatrie
parce que cet hiver ça a beaucoup ému la
France et surtout
les médias ont rendu aussi cette
situation très anxiogène je voulais
savoir si pour les
cet hiver qui va venir comment est-ce
que vous allez anticiper ou est-ce que
comment est-ce qu'on peut
disons changer aussi au niveau des
stocks changer au niveau de la
communication et mieux organiser et
comment est-ce que si les médecins ont
dit on consomme le plus de
d'antibiotiques en France comment est-ce
qu'on peut aussi à ce niveau là
peut-être avoir de la pédagogie un peu
renouvelé cette pédagogie que
l'antibiotique c'est pas tout le temps
et que peut-être les stocks ou la
réorganisation territoriale serait mieux
faite merci
c'est le Ministre oui merci alors le
made in France en fait le sujet
bien sûr des réflexions qui sont en
cours avec la direction des entreprises
il faut assurer ce modèle économique
aussi de ces produits qui sont qui sont
fabriqués en France et on voit bien
l'enjeu qu'on a pu avoir avec l'usine
carlide dans le nord de la France de
maintenir ce modèle économique alors il
y a une circulaire sur les achats
hospitaliers qui intègrent des critères
supérieurs sur la localisation de ces
produits qui permettent aux hôpitaux en
tout cas ça permet de fléchir des fonds
spécifiques pour les hôpitaux pour
qu'ils puissent acheter français si je
veux faire un petit peu résumé et nous
allons avoir cette discussion bien sûr
dans le pdfss 2024 vous en doutez
puisque c'est devenu c'est devenu un
enjeu un enjeu majeur maintenant tout de
tout le sujet du prix des médicaments
est revenu sur la table on va voir les
conclusions de ce groupe de travail
porté par la première ministre mais en
tout cas cette préoccupation du fabriqué
en France fabriqué en Europe et bien
réel dans dans l'aide qu'on doit pouvoir
apporter aux hôpitaux pour acheter des
produits qui sont qui sont fabriqués en
France il serait il serait peu efficace
d'avoir une politique de relocalisation
et de continuer à acheter à l'étranger
parce qu'il y a une différence de prix
importante en tout cas ça fait bien
partie du sujet et madame la sénatrice
concernant de l'hiver à venir et je vous
rejoins sur le rôle particulièrement
anxiogène des médias dans cette dans
cette crise on a bien vu merci on a bien
vu dans le cadre effectivement du
paracétamol de l'amoxicilline des
véritables tensions importantes pas des
ruptures complètes des tensions
importantes prioritairement sur des sur
des des
formes des formes pédiatriques et c'est
ça qui a pu qui a pu plus s'inquiéter la
remarque est importante parce que ça
veut dire que sur des plus adulte on
avait quand même encore de la
disponibilité et qu'on avait quand même
la possibilité de traiter donc ça c'est
ça c'est important par contre on a vu
après sur là aussi dans les médias une
certaine
agitation sur des molécules qui
n'étaient pour le coup par pas en
rupture de cette différence entre la
réalité des faits et la réalité qui peut
être ressentie même si quand il y a des
tensions et s'il y en a aussi à saluer
le rôle des pharmaciens d'officine qui a
été majeur ils ont passé beaucoup de
temps à aller chercher pour leur pour
leur patients dans d'autres dans
d'autres pharmacies c'est une remarque
sur un produit dont on a beaucoup parlé
dans la presse qui est un produit anti
épileptique qui est revenu régulièrement
en avant il n'y avait pas effectivement
de rupture il y avait des tensions mais
on a toujours eu ce produit à
disposition simplement la procédure et
c'est là tout l'importance de la
transparence à la procédure est un petit
peu changé il fallait que le pharmacien
demande le produit directement au
laboratoire et dans les 48 heures il
était livré et toutes les demandes qui
ont été faites au laboratoire ont été à
100% respectés dans ce délai de 48
heures on a pu aussi avoir des
interrogations sur la pilule abortive
dont on ne manquait pas c'était
simplement à conditionnement de un seul
comprimé qui était en difficulté dans
les officines mais les conditionnements
en 16 comprimés qui avaient dans les
hôpitaux et les saisies donc toujours
été toujours été fournis donc il n'y
avait pas ce phénomène réel de rupture
alors communiquer c'est pour moi
effectivement essentiel communiquer
auprès de la population et la campagne
de santé publique France est déjà un
premier élément avant l'été et on sera
amené à la répéter communiquer auprès
des professionnels vous avez entièrement
raison sur le bon usage des
antibiotiques pour discuter
régulièrement avec avec des
professionnels de santé c'est pas tant
le professionnel de santé que les
patients qui sont aussi très très
demandeurs d'antibiotiques donc il faut
bien jouer sur les deux niveaux
d'information
et c'est tout l'intérêt des mesures
mises en place je vous disais tout à
l'heure comme les trodes qui permet aux
pharmaciens avant de donner un
antibiotique de faire une vérification
et de dire attendez c'est pas nécessaire
c'est une angine virale c'est pas une
angine bactérienne donc il y a pas
besoin de d'antibiotiques renouveler la
pédagogie auprès des médecins oui c'est
là aussi une campagne d'information qui
est importante alors pour l'hiver à
venir et bien cette cartographie des
risques est faite pour les médicaments
les plus essentiels nous sommes en cours
de discussion avec les laboratoires les
plus concernés sur les produits pour
justement voir avec eux si nous
garantissent une capacité d'augmentation
de production ou si on envisage de faire
des stocks pour l'hiver c'est des
discussions sont en ce moment avec les
laboratoires concernés
merci beaucoup Laurence Muller Braun et
puis ensuite dernière série de questions
de la rapporteur
monsieur le ministre vous avez parlé
comme solution il y a quelques temps sur
les médias comme solution pénurie des
vieux traitements des vieux médicaments
vous avez parlé des traitements
innovants alors qu'entendez-vous par ces
traitements innovants
quels sont-ils pour quelle maladie sous
le mot innovant on peut tous imaginer
quelquefois c'est tout simple une
modification à la marge de la part des
laboratoires et qui vont faire passer
donc ces traitements pour innovants donc
quels sont-ils comment pourrait aider à
la pénurie des médicaments
[Musique]
oui alors moi je suis toujours par
rapport aux propos et aux réponses en
fait que vous nous avez apporté avoir
encore des des
précisions
vous avez beaucoup parlé de la
transparence nous partageons ici au
niveau de la commission
d'enquête la nécessité de transport je
veux dire que le CEPS fait un travail
extrêmement important pas facile avec un
pas un grand nombre de de personnes
d'ailleurs au niveau du CEPS mais
est-ce que vous ne croyez pas que
justement la transparence à tous les
niveaux et notamment au niveau des prix
serait un facteur qui pourrait être
utile y compris pour le gouvernement
pour peser et pour éviter cette
inflation au niveau des prix parce que
là il y a une grande une grande opacité
ça c'est ma première ma première
remarque ma deuxième remarque c'est que
je reviens quand même sur
[Musique]
deuxième question c'est sur vous avez
parlé effectivement
semblait que vous êtes allé dans dans le
sens de des propositions que je vous
soumettais concernant la fabrication de
d'une part publique sur un certain
nombre de médicaments restreints une
cinquantaine etc pourquoi pas et vous
avez même dit y compris de médicaments
abandonnés ça fait tilt parce que nous
avons auditionné le laboratoire
notamment d'elbert qui nous est dit que
ils étaient en grande difficulté par
rapport justement à la fabrication
parfois quand il voulait reprendre des
médicaments abandonnés et eux nous l'ont
dit mais d'autres nous l'ont dit par
exemple et bien ils n'ont pas alors moi
je vais le dire de manière un peu
familière mais ils n'ont pas la recette
de du médicament et parfois ils sont
obligés vraiment ils galèrent pour
arriver à produire et on nous l'a aussi
dit d'ailleurs dans les dans les
pharmacies dans les pharmacies centrales
donc qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
pour obliger que quand on aborde quand
on a labo abandonne une molécule il
abandonne pas seulement la molécule mais
également le secret de fabrication si je
puis dire et enfin
[Musique]
je reviens sur la GEPS je vous ai parlé
quand même de suppression de 30 à 40
emploient plein annoncé donc est-ce que
là il ne peut pas y avoir une
intervention forte déterminée du
ministre que vous êtes parce que ça va
obligatoirement des conséquences par
rapport à la production donc à la
pénurie de médicaments et du coup je
vous pose la question parce que alors
c'est quelque chose de compliqué mais
c'est il y a un article dans le code de
la santé publique r5124-69
sur le le droit à la concurrence vous
savez que
la GEPS n'a pas n'a pas le droit d'être
en concurrence avec avec le privé mais
finalement si on constate que un labo ne
fait pas ne rend pas le service sur un
ami qui est exploité est-ce qu'on peut
pas contrevenir enfin modifier cet
article pour permettre à la GEPS ou aux
pharmacies centrale de de faire ce
d'intervenir à ce moment là précis ça
nécessiterait de modifier cet article
mais est-ce que le jeu n'en vaut pas la
chandelle
merci c'est le Ministre oui merci madame
la Présidente concernant tout d'abord la
question des traitements innovants alors
traitement innovant ce sont des
traitements qui qui apportent un service
médical supérieur bien entendu sont des
traitements qui peuvent apparaître dès
la phase 2 des essais cliniques
idéalement ensuite ils sont complétés
bien sûr par une par une phase 3 alors
nous avons différentes
procédures pour ces traitements
innovants bien sûr on ne met pas sur le
marché des traitements sans une analyse
de ces mêmes traitements la procédure de
l'accès précoce et une une procédure qui
nous permet de mettre sur le marché des
médicaments plutôt d'ailleurs d'une
façon générale un an avant la majorité
des pays européens c'est une procédure
qui est accélérée mais qui respecte bien
entendu l'ensemble de notre circuit de
validation tout d'abord un avis de la de
la Haute Autorité de Santé bien entendu
qui sur des données scientifiques permet
de voir
l'efficacité de ce produit et qui juge
de l'efficacité de ce produit la vie est
également de la NSM mais surtout ce qui
est intéressant c'est que maintenant la
possibilité d'utiliser des mises sur le
marché conditionnelles sur la base d'un
avis de l'Agence européenne du
médicament nous permet de mettre de
mettre ces produits très innovants à
disposition de nos concitoyens plus
rapidement ça a été le cas par exemple
récemment par le truc rue Velda truelle
va chez jamais entre les deux qui est un
médicament pour le cancer du sein triple
négatif qui a des résultats
particulièrement intéressants reste et
je crois
que des interrogations sur vous savez
qu'il y a cet asmr qui est donné de 1 4
sur les produits très innovants il reste
une interrogation sur la smrp 5 pour
être tout à fait clair avec vous la SMR
5 regroupe deux classes de produits sur
lesquels nous sommes en train de
réfléchir à une distinction soit ceux
qui ne font pas mieux que le reste donc
qui n'ont pas de de côté
plus positif pour pour soigner les
patients et donc il n'y a pas forcément
d'intérêt à les mettre sur le marché
rapidement et d'autres pour lesquels il
n'y a pas de comparateur et ça ça reste
une interrogation c'est à dire que quand
le produit est tellement innovant qu'on
ne peut pas le comparer à d'autres
produits il faut qu'on puisse quand même
le mettre le maître sur le sur le marché
on a le sujet des thérapies qui sont
considérées comme thérapie innovante
dans la loi de finances de sécurité
sociale de 23 qui permet de détaler le
paiement de ces produits puisqu'on
parlait beaucoup du prix entre le prix
qui est décidé au départ et les
résultats dans la vie réelle c'est
quelque chose qui se fait patient par
patient et qui est un suivi très
individualisé des efficaces d'efficacité
de ce médicament dans la vie réelle
permettant d'ajuster d'ajuster le prix
et enfin on a aussi des les procédures
d'accès direct qui sont un accélérateur
de mise sur le marché pour des produits
qui ont un asmr de 1 à 4 avant même les
discussions sur le sur le remboursement
et pendant la période de négociation
pour l'élaboration du prix on a la
possibilité par cet accès direct et ça
très positif pour nos concitoyens de le
mettre sur le marché à un prix qui est
fixé et la différence de prix si elle
existe une fois qu'on a défini le prix
avec le CEPS le laboratoire peut être
amené à rembourser la différence de prix
si le prix définitif est plus bas donc
vous voyez qu'on a des procédures sur
ces produits innovants qui toujours
toujours partent sur la base de
l'analyse scientifique faite par la
Haute Autorité de Santé de la pertinence
de l'utilisation de ces produits et de
efficacité
alors madame Cohen concernant les
différents différentes questions nous
nous rejoignons sur sur ces questions de
transparence vous le savez c'est
essentiel à tous les niveaux et
particulièrement au niveau du prix vous
avez entièrement raison malheureusement
nous sommes en face un peu près
systématiquement de du secret des
affaires qui est très difficile d'avoir
cette transparence totale sur
l'élaboration réelle du prix ici
si on affiche les vrais prix ça va être
parfois compliqué déjà c'est difficile
de les avoir c'est compliqué pour les
laboratoires qui ne voudraient plus
commercialiser en France s'ils affichent
un prix plus bas que dans d'autres pays
européens donc on a là aussi un enjeu de
maintenir le marché avec avec les
différents les différents industriels
pour autant le prix qui est défini en
France reste un prix de référence pour
nombreux pays également au niveau au
niveau européen
ces règles aussi je crois que c'est
important sur le prix c'est que ce n'est
pas un prix qui est qui est fixe et
définitif il y a une dynamique au niveau
des prix et il est important de la tenir
de la prendre en compte bien entendu
sur
pénalité conditionnalités
je vous rejoins il faut certainement
aller plus loin dans les mesures que
nous mettons en place et ça rejoint un
peu ce que l'on disait sur sur ce
vademecom probablement à mettre en
visibilité dans le cadre de ce vin des
mecs et des exigences là aussi un
travail qui est multifultime ministre
interministériel pour le couple entre
des exigences que pour avoir l'industrie
et moi les exigences que je dois avoir
sur la mise à disponibilité de ce
produit et la garantie que nous soyons
pas en rupture rupture de stock alors
les médicaments abandonnés là aussi je
ne peux que souscrire à votre remarque
c'est finalement tout le sujet de la
mise à disposition des brevets comment
là aussi malheureusement des règles qui
ne dépendent pas que des règles de la de
la santé à ce sujet concernant le GEPS
et sur les emplois du GIPS on disait
tout à l'heure
très honnêtement cette information donc
nous allons nous allons regarder ça de
très près et voir exactement ce qu'il en
est et d'où viennent ces annonces et si
elles sont fondées et comment enfin ce
qu'il y a un petit peu un petit peu
derrière tout comme cet article R51
24-69 que de toute évidence il nous faut
regarder de très près sur votre remarque
qui serait de confier au GPS non pas
uniquement lorsque le médicament n'est
pas produit mais également lorsqu'il y a
une défaillance des industrielles il me
semble il me semble que nous pouvons
déjà utiliser cet article puisque ce que
nous avons fait cet hiver pendant la
période de pénurie répond exactement à
cette problématique et donc nous avons
pu nous avons pu l'utiliser donc je
pense que si le cas devait se reproduire
nous ferions de même
très bien pour faire un peu d'humour
comme quoi toutes nos auditions seront
pas scrutées avec la même attention
puisque c'était quand même un témoignage
de la chèvre ce genre d'une des audition
la suppression des postes
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres questions mes
chers collègues
et bien monsieur le ministre nous vous
remercions beaucoup de
ces réponses et puis
nous rendrons-nous nos propositions
assez vite
il y aura certainement des convergences
mais il y aura aussi des
complémentarités
qui de toute façon depuis le rapport du
Sénat de l'été 2018 où il y a eu à
l'époque que 700 pénurie et ce qui était
déjà vécu de façon fort logiquement
assez terrible par les par les patients
il est temps qu'on accélère et donc
toutes les contributions seront
évidemment utiles et en tout cas vous
pouvez compter sur le Sénat pour
apporter une liste ferme de propositions
qu'il faudra désormais prendre en compte
de façon beaucoup plus ferme qu'en 2018
je vous remercie beaucoup Monsieur le
Ministre merci merci madame la
Présidente juste me permettre juste une
demande est-ce que vos conclusions vous
avez à peu près une une temporalité
parce que comme je dois sortir la
feuille de route on a bien compris que
la temporalité était un élément
important pour notre commission
d'enquête du ministère en tout cas
au début juillet première semaine de
juillet
puisque l'objectif de cette commission
d'enquête c'est évidemment de faire
avancer le sujet pour le bien public
voilà merci beaucoup